bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde
ce que l'Europe doit aux Juifs la
civilisation européenne s'est construite
siècle après siècles génération après
génération du génie de ces populations
des événements politiques militaires
religieux d'un extraordinaire brassage
culturel et géographique et d'innovation
de tous ordres qui ont contribué au
progrès de l'humanité et à
l'universalité des valeurs les Juifs ont
leur part leur influence selon Pierre
Manan dans ce chemin civilisationnel
participant à toutes les aventures de
l'esprit avec l'intelligence des
modernes selon le sociologue Émile
Durkheim en demeurant et je cite
toujours citoyen d'après Jean-Jacques
Rousseau et en cultivant une altérité
ancestrale à rechercher du côté des
origines bibliques est à ludiques de
leurs épreuves
circulaire et d'une aptitude
socioculturelle remarquable ce
cheminement côte à côte des Juifs et de
l'Europe objet de notre émission sera
moins à géographie ou apologétique ni
sacralisation ni éblouissement
simplement il s'agira de discerner
l'influence de la pensée juive dans
l'histoire de la philosophie de la
politique des sciences des arts des
religions et tout simplement des
comportements qui ont fait l'Europe
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui et peut-être de
demain je vous propose une espèce de
narration
biographique de ce que l'Europe doit aux
Juifs avec mes invités Vincent Peillon
vous êtes ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale vous êtes philosophe Pascal
Laurie vous êtes historien de l'Académie
française Armand lafférrer vous êtes
normale
Pierre Nora vous êtes historien de
l'Académie française
vous avez vu ce que Milan coudeira du
dit du génie juif étranger partout et
partout chez eux comment expliquer vous
Vincent payant que l'esprit juif cultive
cette contradiction apparente entre
garder une distance et être dans la
proximité en somme de conjuguer
l'universel et le particularisme
bon d'abord c'est sans doute le danger
de notre thème on le voit c'est c'est
qu'on embrasse très large et qu'on peut
mal étreindre alors bon si je veux
répondre à votre question je dirais deux
choses la première chose il y a sans
doute quelque chose qui est d'ordre
historique c'est-à-dire un peuple élu
qui a un rapport direct avec Dieu et une
mission accomplir à une mission qui
n'est pas une mission pour lui-même mais
qui est une mission universelle mais
précisément et donc vous voyez bien que
vous avez déjà une articulation entre un
particulier puisque est un peuple
singulier élu mais élu pas pour regarder
son nombril ou se faire du bien à
lui-même élu pour porter un message qui
va d'ailleurs après s'amplifier dans
l'histoire qui est un message
universaliste cette tension va
historiquement ce ce durcir du fait que
alors c'est après ce qu'on va appeler le
judaïsme des rabbins parce que le
conflit entre une secte juive qui
s'appelle le christianisme et le
christianisme originaire qui est celui
des Juifs va être un une tension
justement entre deux universels et la
clôture juive ça va être une façon de
préserver ce lien singulier entre le
particulier et l'universel alors c'est
le deuxième point on pourrait penser en
tout cas un certain nombre de
philosophes proposent qu'il y a et c'est
très actuel par rapport au débat qu'on a
même politique en France deux types
d'universels un universel chrétien au
sens de l'Impérium de l'Empire
c'est-à-dire je réunis tout le monde
mais il faut que ce soit le même bon
donc je te demande de renoncer à ta
différence et un universalisme juif qui
lui dirait l'universel se construit dans
le respect de toutes les différences le
juif n'est pas prosélyte le juif ne
convertit pas des philosophes comme les
vinaast ou André nerf ont beaucoup
insisté sur cette idée qui nous amène
aussi à réfléchir sur le sens que peut
avoir le républicainiste français
l'intégration et l'assimilation on va
rentrer dans le détail mais juste un mot
comment vous distinguer les Brahim du
judaïsme bon alors est-ce que vous avez
tendance à dire qu'avant c'était les
Brahim puis le judaïsme des rabbins est
venu après mais il n'y a pas une
filiation directe direct sans doute mais
vous avez deux voix différentes vous
avez une voix qui est celle de
l'hébraïsme c'est-à-dire d'un peuple qui
a existé historiquement qui vivait sous
la loi de Moïse que vous avez dans le
pentateux et auquel un certain nombre de
savants par exemple au XIXe il faut
revenir c'est là que vous avez le modèle
chez Spinoza de la République des
Hébreux et puis vous avez le judaïsme
alors là c'est autre chose c'est
d'autres textes c'est une tradition qui
va exister tout au long du Moyen-Âge qui
va produire des textes qui va produire
une tradition il y a même dans le
judaïsme par exemple français au 19e
siècle un conflit entre les uns et les
autres puisque certains disent il faut
revenir à libraïsme c'est-à-dire au
judaïsme des origines dans le détail et
quitter le judaïsme des rabbins qui est
dans le fond un judaïsme trop orthodoxe
fermée sur lui-même
de du plutôt que de l'esprit on va
rentrer dans le détail en pierre Nora je
pense que vous vouliez dire un mot là
sur cette distinction entre le peu
l'universel et le particularisme
moi je suis un peu dépassé par ce sujet
j'avoue et
auquel j'aurais tendance à propos je
pense que je suis seul Juif ça pardon
pas du tout non
parce que je me serais permis vous
n'avez pas vous n'avez pas cette
exclusivité
et que Marx
tout ça c'est quand même les Jésus
donc et Jésus ça fait beaucoup de
troubles dans la cité antique les trois
que vous avez cités sont universelles
oui oui qu'est-ce que vous leur trouve
qu'en Europe qu'est-ce que vous leur
trouvez particuliers ils ont apporté la
peste le j'ai quand même perdu
totalitarisme contemporain du communisme
qui a empoisonné le monde le deuxième
est totalité de l'inconscient qui
a lui aussi
compliqué les choses singulièrement je
plaisante bien sûr vous m'avez compris
et
l'expérience plus récente de la Shoah
interprète interpréter beaucoup de
choses et je crois que votre réponse
monsieur Mallet il faudrait d'abord
distinguer aussi plusieurs types de
judaïsme le judaïsme des pays assimilé
de l'Europe si j'ose dire n'est pas du
tout le même que le pays que le judaïsme
des pays orientaux par l'histoire c'est
la même chose
rare destin ça n'est pas le même et même
par l'histoire ça n'a pas été du tout la
même du tout la même juste le judaïsme
européen et spécialement français
a été jusque à la Shoah un judaïsme
d'assimilation très puissant et qui s'il
n'y avait pas eu probablement lâchera ce
serait achevé par l'assimilation
complète et à la limite la disparition
du judaïsme
en Orient c'est quand même complètement
la même chose dans l'Europe orientale
c'est totalement judaïs beaucoup plus
démocratique beaucoup plus populaire
beaucoup plus
ethnique beaucoup plus communautarisme
et leur destin a quand même pas été le
même
justement dans l'examination à l'est il
a été
sinon radical du moins attendu à l'être
en France en particulier il a été
beaucoup plus
scrupuleux si j'ose dire et donc à tous
ces égards il y a eu plusieurs
formes de vie en Europe et
personnellement ce qui m'a le plus
intéressé c'est le judaïsme français qui
a évidemment un destin qui lui est très
particulier et qui est profondément lié
à la France cité on va rentrer donc vous
allez voir on va en parler peut-être à
bon la ferraire sur cette distinction
entre le pari d'universalité est quand
même un particularisme qui se qui se
montre le jeudi c'est un peu le lieu où
finalement cette distinction perd
beaucoup de son sens le judaïsme c'est
un peuple enfin les Juifs sont un peuple
ne m'ont pas l'intention d'être autre
chose
et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont apporté quand
même la pensée européenne
fondamentalement l'idée qu'il y avait un
seul Dieu et un seul moral et une seule
morale pardon c'est à dire
l'universalité la plus absolue et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui une partie des
peuples européens
ont un ressentiment profond envers cette
idée que il y a une morale qui va
au-delà du fait que on défend notre
tribu on massacre celle d'à côté et
après on boit et après on boit un verre
et le fond
c'est un sujet gigantesque les relations
entre l'Europe et les Juifs et
d'ailleurs il y a une série de
conférences qui sont qui ont commencé et
qui se feront sur 2023
sous l'égide d'un certain Emile Mallet
donc peut-être que c'était le moment le
moment de le signaler mais
l'apport d'un message universel par un
peuple qui tient à sa particularité et
au cœur de d'une relation qui du coup
forcément devait être compliquée parce
que nous avons dit finalement aux
Européens nous avons un message pour
vous qui vaut pour tout le monde et à
part ça ne nous embêtez pas lorsque nous
ferons notre propre petite chose
Monsieur la Ferrer est-ce que vous
voulez dire qu'il y a un message
d'éternité
c'est un message d'éternité il y a un
message d'éternité parce que l'Éternel
comme son nom l'indique mais c'est
surtout un message d'universalité
apporté au même moment où nous avons
refusé toutes les ambitions européennes
à l'universalité européenne et autres
parce qu'il y a les musulmans aussi il y
a eu des vagues comme ça idéologiques
tout le monde doit être chrétien c'est
la solution tout le monde doit être
musulman tout le monde doit être
rationaliste c'est
68 on disait que tout le monde devait
être juif tout le monde tout le monde
doit être socialiste enfin il y a eu des
messages comme ça et des grandes vérités
universelles et à chaque fois il y avait
des petites il y avait un petit peuples
qui disait vous êtes gentil c'est très
bien ce que vous dites mais moi je vais
aller agiter mon doulave et finalement
ce que ça donne et c'est le même peu et
c'est le même peuple qui avait dit aussi
vous avez la morale c'est sérieux Dieu
c'est sérieux et c'est quelque chose qui
vaut pour tout le monde et c'est
forcément ça ne pouvait être en partie
conflictuelle même s'il n'a pas été dit
merci que conflit alors Pascal auri je
un tout petit peu plus loin avec vous et
vous chatouiller sur le côté historien
vous avez eu Jean-Jacques Rousseau dit
les Juifs sont toujours citoyens comment
vous expliquez cette chose là
citoyen toujours citoyens de
prédestination
citoyen à cette tardif par rapport à la
plupart des chrétiens de ces
institutions politiques des sciences
chrétiennes qui constituent grosso modo
l'Occident mais je voudrais répondre aux
questions que vous posez depuis le début
de l'émission tout à fait par une
remarque concernant en fait un groupe
qui n'a pas encore été cité qui me
paraît capitale pour comprendre le fait
que le statut des Juifs a changé qui
sont les protestants
parce que il y a une sorte de remarque
presque triviale que je voudrais faire
quelque peu issu de d'un travail récent
sur la judéophobie
pourquoi et comment est-ce que
le statut des Juifs va bouger pour
simplifier à partir du 16e siècle le 17e
18e bon comme well la Révolution
française
les différents édits tolérance
l'émancipation du peuple juif la réponse
est quand même vertigineuse c'est drôle
personne n'y pense pas parce qu'il y a
eu une révolte juive je sache je prends
une grosse loupe je la trouve pas
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il s'est passé
un changement chez les goy ben oui c'est
là que ça se passe actuellement tout le
monde en question il y aurait toujours
la situation
bon donc
c'est évidemment quelque chose qui s'est
passé là et le protestantisme la réforme
était essentielle parce que on sait
qu'on peut avoir un regard sur Luther ou
sur Calvin assez
critique dans leur évolution surtout
voilà il y a l'autre surtout à Luther
regard des Juifs mais il n'en reste pas
moins que là où ça commence à bouger à
la fin du XVIème siècle s'échappe pour
simplifier les calvinistes chez un homme
croissant de pasteurs et tout simplement
pourquoi mais c'est pas difficile encore
aujourd'hui au moment où nous parlons
quel est dans le christianisme le lieu
qui a une référence vétéo testamentaire
donc c'est le protestantisme donc il est
évident que là il s'est passé quelque
chose d'essentiel et donc d'une certaine
façon l'avenir du peuple juif elle est
passée par le protestantisme il faudrait
quand même que le rappeler moderne mais
qui est quand même plus tardif ben non
16e 16e siècle avant ça avant ça ne
bouge fondamentalement alors écoute et
puisqu'on parle de bouger alors je
voudrais vous poser cette question de
Théodore Reina car Ernest Renan il y a
ce sentiment que le Juif exprime
l'esprit moderne
ce que le philosophe français Vladimir
yankelevitch nomme la motilité juive
est-ce que c'est une avancée de
civilisation qui ainsi apporter et
est-ce que c'est ce qui est apporté à la
civilisation européenne ses grandes
transformations
les philosophes et les politologues que
le débat qu'il a soulevé d'abord ce
qu'il dit était absolument juste
historiquement pourquoi parce que les
protestants disent il faut revenir au
texte même c'est Luther sur la scriptura
ça veut dire je vais lire directement le
texte sans passer par une église un
prêtre en interprète mais le texte c'est
quoi c'est ce qu'on appelle la Bible
hébraïque donc à ce moment-là s'ouvre
dans toute l'Europe les chairs des
brahimes etc et il y a un retour à ce
moment-là du judaïsme ou en tout cas de
l'hébraïsme de la Bible hébraïque dans
la civilisation devenue chrétienne mais
mais la vraie question qui se pose
depuis maintenant une quinzaine d'années
pour les chercheurs c'est de savoir
qu'est-ce qui revient avec la Bible
hébraïque parce que le grand processus
de la sécularisation de la modernité
donc vous parlez il n'a produit pas les
Juifs on dit les origines chrétiennes de
l'Europe moi j'étais au Parlement
européen on parlait pas des origines
juives de l'Europe or qu'est-ce qui se
passe au 16e et 17e siècle la vraie
question ayant un professeur d'arvard
qui s'appelle Eric Nelson qui a publié
il y a 10 ans un livre qui s'appelle La
République des Hébreux qui est
maintenant dans le monde entier qui a
été ce grand débat historique il dit
mais attention la modernité dont vous
parlez c'est quoi républicanisme
tolérance redistribution par la justice
sociale ces trois éléments n'étaient pas
présents dans la culture réformée mais
les réformés et évidemment les
calvinistes lorsqu'il lisent la Bible
hébraïque découvre la République des
Hébreux et dans la République des
Hébreux le dialogue avec David nous ne
voulons pas de roi
le républicanisme n'est plus une
solution parmi d'autres comme chez les
Grecs on peut être monarchiste
républicain non là ils disent c'est le
meilleur modèle il faut pas de roi
deuxièmement il y a chez les Juifs une
loi qui ressemble à la loi agraire dans
le fond qui est la remise des dettes
tous les les 6 ans et tous les 50 ans on
doit libérer les esclaves et remettre
les dettes ça c'est la justice
redistributive qui n'existait plus dans
la pensée des humanistes de la
Renaissance ou après et troisièmement la
tolérance dont on imagine jamais qu'elle
est d'origine juive mais il y a un
théologico-politique juif non prosély je
le disais tout à l'heure qui est pour le
pluralisme des croyances et donc la
thèse et c'est vrai que c'est par les
protestants mais c'est les Juifs qui
parlent le protestantisme amène la
culture de la modernité et dans la
Révolution anglaise puis dans la
Révolution française par exemple les
textes de Rousseau sur la République des
Hébreux moi j'ai découvert très tard
alors que j'avais lu Rousseau il était
au programme de l'agrégation et on le
voyait pas il écrit très précisément sur
la République des Hébreux c'est un
modèle politique qui va fonctionner dans
les révolutions de la modernité on le
retrouve aussi chez les fondateurs aux
États-Unis donc vous avez un modèle
politique qui vient par les protestants
pour l'histoire de la lecture directe
mais qui est un modèle spécifiquement
juif et la question la modernité c'est
quoi c'est la grande question des
historiens des philosophes dans le monde
est-ce que disait Foucault nous
interrogeons maintenant sur qui
sommes-nous en permanence notre
actualité la modernité la réponse la
modernité est juive et tout le XIXe
siècle dont parlait tout à l'heure
Pierre Nora tout le 19e siècle français
et alors en particulier dans la culture
juive française après les saint
simoniens qui ont intégré le syncymonie
les Juifs c'est une interrogation sur
cette question qu'est-ce que nous
apportons pourquoi nous sommes modernes
et juifs le commerce international la
tolérance la démocratie le refus des
lois et la justice sociale tous ces
éléments sont des éléments tout à fait
fondamentaux dans la modernité au point
que le premier rabbin libéral de Paris à
la synagogue Copernic dit même le
judaïve qui s'appelait Louis Germain
Lévy le judaïs sera la religion laïque
de la France moderne parce que c'est la
religion la plus capable voir les
procédures talmudiques d'intégrer les
progrès de la science et en même temps
les progrès de la démocratie libérale
alors sur cette idée de modernité Pierre
Nora dans une étrange obstination votre
dernier livre vous parlez de ces grands
intellectuels du 20e siècle qui ont été
vos compagnons de route je pense à
Foucault les bistrots etc est-ce que
vous aviez ce sentiment là que entre
judaïsme et modernité il y avait une
filiation directe la modernité n'est pas
forcément un progrès comme
on l'a beaucoup dit c'est c'est pas du
tout du tout un projet vous-même vous
vous êtes intéressé beaucoup à la vie
intellectuelle c'est pas forcément
content non plus il y a pas de progrès
dans le véritables progrès aux choses de
la vie intellectuelle et on peut pas
dire forcément
les bistrots puisque vous parlez des
bistrots a bien montré qu'il n'y avait
pas de progrès de l'humanité que et il
pouvait y avoir que les progrès
sectoriels dans la médecine tous les
domaines il peut y avoir évidemment des
progrès mais que en termes globaux du
magniton ne peut pas parler de progrès
l'invention de de l'écriture qui a été a
priori les grandes conquêtes de
l'humanité elle a servi et il le montre
très bien à dominé
à permettre à des ordres d'aller un peu
plus que ce que la voix permettait de
toucher et donc que c'était un
instrument d'écrasement et domination et
d'impérialisme est-ce du progrès c'est
pas du progrès c'est alors
incontestablement une forme de progrès
de l'humanité et en même temps c'est le
début de la poème
c'est vous-même donc ça veut pas il y a
pas de progrès humain non pierre n'aura
vous avez signalé vous-même que vous
étiez juif sinon moi j'en aurais pas
parlé oui mais est-ce que vous pensez
que cette chose là vous a
prédéterminé à avoir le cheminement que
vous avez comme intellectuel comme
historien comme j'allais dire un peu
stratège du champ des idées
en tous les cas et mais c'est pour
répondre à votre question je crois pas
qu'on puisse et attribuer
aux Juifs l'idée même de la modalité
sauf
que au départ du départ ils ont apporté
à l'humanité tout entière ce sont
laquelle elle ne serait pas l'humanité
que nous connaissons c'est à dire la loi
c'est quand même les inventeurs de la
loi à travers les commandements donc
l'idée même de la loi à la base
c'est une idée qui dispose de la
transcendance
et donc qui fait l'humanité se faire
elle-même et donc qui projette le
judaïsme dans une histoire et dans une
histoire bah puisque vous parlez de bon
livre j'essaye de de dire que le
judaïsme n'est pas une religion et c'est
une histoire
et un lieu de mémoire le christianisme
est une religion
et l'islam me semble-t-il est plutôt une
culture que le religion
et donc c'est très difficile de dire que
c'est que de religion je crois pas que
le juriste en soit une
c'est un élément fondamental de
l'humanité qui est né avec la loi
sur ces points là je voudrais
peut-être complété ce qu'a dit je suis
parfaitement d'accord et puis ajouter un
point sur le fait que tout ne se fait
pas toujours dans le même sens je
voudrais compléter un apport qui n'est
pas mentionné directement
par l'ouvrage que vous avez cité mais
qui était également considérable c'est
l'apport du scepticisme par rapport au
pouvoir la plus grande partie des
cultures humaines historiquesment font
du pouvoir quelque chose de central
d'absolu le pharaon est un dieu
l'empereur de Perse est un dieu je me
suis Poutine n'est pas un Dieu mais si
on porte comme s'il l'était enfin il y a
cette histoire l'idée que le pouvoir est
absolu à conditionnel les Juifs vont
apporter à l'Europe l'idée que soyons
sérieux la première chose que vous ferez
si vous voulez vraiment un roi on vous
conseille pas mais enfin vous avez le
droit quand même c'est de faire en sorte
qu'il est pas trop d'argent pas trop de
femmes pas trop de chevaux parce que
sinon il va s'il va en abuser et dès
qu'on a un héros et notamment un héros
politique dans le judaïsme et dans des
la Bible donc vraiment dans des tels
très anciens la première chose qu'on
fait c'est la liste de ses défauts de
cet art de ses vistes de ses péchés donc
c'est quelque chose qui a été apporté
mis au débat en disant soyez prudent et
limiter le pouvoir parce que personne
n'en est vraiment digne ça a été repris
via le protestantisme par les
constituants américains à l'époque où la
pensée politique américaine était
probablement celle qui était la plus
développée du monde ça n'a pas duré très
longtemps mais voilà et ça a été intégré
dans la Constitution américaine
satisfaite cette histoire de limitation
donc ça c'est en complément mais je
pense que ça va dans le même sens en
revanche c'est pas seulement les juifs
qui ont apporté à l'Europe il y a eu
aussi un grand avantage donné par la
pensée européenne à la pensée juive sous
la forme des lumières qui s'est traduite
dans la Scala parce que autant pendant
des siècles et des siècles dans ce cas
là étant le mouvement d'émancipation
jusqu'à lors le débat se faisait
franchement en point de vue du point de
la sophistication en ego c'est-à-dire
que lorsque
Maïmonide commente les Grecs il est
aussi bon que il montre que voilà ça
saisit il y a pas de autant au 18e
siècle les lumières et quelque chose qui
est quelque chose qui est parti qui a
démarré sans les Juifs et heureusement
que on a pu les rattraper parce que les
quelques courants qui les ont refusé
sont les courants du judaïsme qui se
sont fossilisés
Pascal aurait voulu dire quelque chose
je n'ai pas une compétence philosophique
suffisante pour intervenir dans un
discussion qui est comme centrale pour
cette émission sur la contribution
intellectuelle rit pas de la pensée
Juifs pluraliser à la modernité ce que
je constate en revanche en tant que
modeste historien c'est que premièrement
effectivement les les Juifs n'ont pas la
pensée juive le judaïsme les Juifs ont
perçu que la modernité leur était
favorable que bien entendu la tolérance
et ça c'est capital parce souvent
investir symboliquement réellement dans
le cas d'histoire française sur laquelle
on va revenir sans doute les Juifs
d'État n'en parle pierre Birdo mais on
va en parler donc il est clair là sur ce
plan il y a une association et puis
deuxième preuve les antisémites pensent
tous enfin plutôt et aussi les
antisémites de tradition
religieuses bon il y a pense évidemment
que les destructeurs des traditions ces
moderniste dangereux ce sont les Juifs
donc il y a une sorte de d'accord sur ce
plan là pour le pour le reste je
voudrais quand même rappeler puisque on
évoque le christianisme pour moi c'est
une thèse que j'ai défendu dans un
ouvrage l'origine de la judéophobie ne
peut être que chrétienne ça c'est un
vaste problème c'est un autre problème
ben oui oui parce que on va les
polythéistes n'ont pas de problème vous
allez voir on va en parler
alors les Juifs sont républicains avant
la République c'est pas trop provocateur
ça Vincent payant est-ce qu'elle se
républicanisme juif qui anticipe les
révolutions françaises peut-être
américaines ce que vous allez pas trop
loin non vous savez c'est ce qui est
stupéfiant c'est notre propre ignorance
souvent et elle est politique dans le
fond pourquoi nous voulons nous ne
voulons pas savoir entre je le redis le
16e et le 17e il y a plusieurs centaines
de livres qui sont publiés en Europe
dans le titre et la République des
Hébreux c'est vrai en Italie c'est vrai
en langue au Pays-Bas où sont bons et
moi bon j'ai fait mes études j'ai écrit
une quinzaine d'ouvrages
j'ai découvert ça très tardivement ça ne
m'a jamais été enseigné
parce que l'histoire comme disait le
maître Alexandre Cauet passé serait
écrit tout le temps mais se passer là on
l'avait oublié donc il y a un certain
boulot je vous indique quand même c'est
exactement pareil pour la France moi je
suis je peux lire maintenant je ne suis
plus ministre je suis un juif de la
République mon grand-père était on a un
grand-père le grand rabbin de Mulhouse
je suis une famille qui a été touchée
par la Shoah je suis mort mais comme
ministre de la République je n'avais pas
le dire les Juifs de la République
agissent dans la République avec des
valeurs qui ne leur posent aucun
problème pourquoi pour la raison que
vous venez de dire et qui est très
précoce c'est-à-dire que ce modèle
républicain lorsque les Juifs sont
émancipés dans la Révolution française
il considère il considère que le modèle
politique qui est en train de construire
la France républicaine correspond à leur
valeur et ils ne sont pas là passivement
c'est l'assimilation ils sont là
activement quel autre pays que la France
a eu deux ministres Juifs en 1848 1848
deux ministres Juifs les finances et le
droit nous avons eu un premier ministre
alors que l'Europe l'Europe était sous
la coupe nazie en 36 Léon Blum nous
avons eu l'un d'espace nous avons parce
que c'est fou la République qui sont pas
obligés de dire je suis juif tous les
matins mais qui savent ce que être juif
on la famille a transmis les valeurs du
judaïsme qui les transmettent à leur
proposant sont à l'aise dans cette
république et ça c'est c'est très tôt et
donc c'est simplement notre ignorance
qui fait qu'on peut être mais Platon
disait faut être étonné pour commencer à
connaître oui et bien en Europe il y a
eu 200 livres qui s'appelaient la
République des Hébreux sous sous
l'impulsion des protestants je le
reconnais bien au 17e et au 16e siècle
maintenant dans la République française
il est évident qu'il y a un problème
intellectuel en France le suivant si et
moi quand je faisais mes études vous me
dites bon qui sont les grands penseurs
juifs j'ai aucun problème Martin Bieber
François etc c'est ça que nous étudions
à la Sorbonne ils sont tous allemands
comme egalie de guerre catch meet
maintenant que tu es nazi quand même
voilà mais il y avait des Juifs en
France il y a eu l'émancipation il y
avait des Juifs dans l'université
française plus que dans l'université
allemande au XIXe universitaires
allemands viennent en France parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas être non les
étudie pas d'où mon gros livre sur
Joseph Salvador et et Jérusalem n'est
pas perdu parce que voilà un juif
français d'une dimension considérable
qui écrit dès 1822 noix de Moïse qui a
une influence considérable sur lequel on
a jamais écrit le moindre ouvrage en
France j'ai découvert son existence dans
un livre d'un historien israélien
Michael Gretz qui avait été traduit je
crois dans les années 90 sur le judaïsme
français de la Révolution française à
l'Alliance israélite universelle et qui
montrait d'ailleurs comment dans le
mouvement du saint simonisme un certain
nombre de juifs ont trouvé les Rodrigues
etc la possibilité d'une intégration
mais d'une intégration pas au prix de
sacrifier leurs différences pas au prix
de sacrifier leur valeur et donc là nous
avons un de travail de recherche et les
plus jeunes que nous à faire dans les
années qui viennent c'est pas seulement
s'intéresser au judaïsme allemand
formidable Cholet François mais il y a
judaïs français qui s'est d'ailleurs
continué justement
Vincent payant Pierre Nora dans la
Ferrer Pascal Laurie j'aimerais que vous
me disiez
entre Léon Blum René cassinge Mandel
Pierre Mendès France Michel Debré ses
enfants Simone Veil en quoi à votre avis
ils sont l'expression du républicanisme
et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont en commun voilà
qui veut parler c'est un sujet qui est
voilà qui veut intervenir là-dessus
parce que est-ce qu'il y a un petit
trait commun est-ce qu'ils ont qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont apporté à la République
peut-être
Armand Laferrière
au fond est-ce que ça fait une belle
Pléiade non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais le trait commun qu'ils ont auraient
pu ne pas être un très commun
spécifiquement juif s'il n'avait pas eu
en face de des antisémites c'est-à-dire
que sont tous
des
personnalités importantes de la
République française ce sont tous c'est
vrai il y a peut-être déjà peut-être
quelque chose là des personnalités
modérées qui sont d'un camp ou de
l'autre
Mandel et blues c'était pas tout à fait
pareil Steven veste encore autre chose
mais à chaque fois
on est donc on a des socialistes ou des
hommes de droite ou des hommes du centre
sans excès je vous rappelle juste cette
chose là Jean-Noël Jeannet a écrit une
pièce de théâtre mettant en scène Léon
Blum mais George Mandel et
c'est à travers le judaïsme qu'ils ont
pu se parler alors sur la politique
alors je vais en ce qu'ils étaient tous
les deux en camp de concentration et
justement c'est un peu ce que j'allais
dire ce que j'allais dire tu as des gens
qui sont des bons républicains et des
modélistes ils ont pas besoin d'être
Juifs ça ce n'est pas lié en revanche
ils ont tous eu en face d'eux des gens
qui disent
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment vous faire
confiance alors que rien ni dans leur
comportement ni dans leur modèle de
pensée
ne s'écartait de la loyauté totale avec
la France la loyauté a quand même été
remise en cause et lorsqu'on se retrouve
effectivement enfermé dans le même temps
de concentration dans la même baraque
par un envahisseur antisémite
qu'on a été des adversaires politiques
mais encore une fois des adversaires
constructifs
forcément il faut en revenir à l'origine
il faut dire peut-être que c'est là en
particulier une partie de la source mais
je crois vraiment que sans antisémite
aucune des personnels toutes les
personnes que vous avez mentionné au
fait la même carrière aurais-tu du point
de vue de la République le même
attachement et
que leur identité juive leur a été
réimposée par la suite même si elle a
contribué à leur formation mais comme
d'autres sources auraient pu le faire
aussi c'est votre avis Pierre Nora je
crois qu'il n'aurait pas fait la même
carrière
Mandel
dit expressément à de Gaulle c'est à
vous d'y aller c'est pas moi
je sais vrai
Mendès France c'est fondamentalement
conditionné dans son rapport à la
politique
par le fait qu'il est juif il y a
peut-être aussi une espèce je sais pas
prononcer le mot mais une forme de
morale
qu'ils ont en commun et
moral je n'ose pas trop le dire
d'humanisme parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui sont humanistes et qui sont
moraux
bien entendu mais en principe il doit y
avoir ça vous me direz à parti prenante
il y a aussi l'inverse le nombre de
gangsters Juifs
harceleur c'est spécialement obsédé
sexuel
donc vous me direz que c'est peut-être
j'ai l'impression qu'en fait on est un
peu d'accord
et que le fait qu'ils étaient juifs et
retenez comme tel était ce qui les a
limités ce qui est clairement ce qui
fait que bordel dit je peux pas y aller
je sais ce qu'on dit ce qu'on en dira la
prise en compte de l'antisémite
que pour tout homme politique juif cette
question se pose et d'ailleurs vous en
êtes averti très tôt par les gens qui
viennent vous le dire qui viennent voilà
et donc il y a toujours une question qui
s'est posée pour ce qui avait
possibilité d'aller au premier rang qui
était est-ce que je ne vais pas faire
même plus de mal que de bien à ma propre
histoire et à ma propre communauté parce
que je vais réveiller de l'antisémitisme
alors on évoquait la France et ce pays
où en 1936 Léon Blum peut être Premier
ministre mais la France est ce pays où
en sortant de l'Assemblée nationale où
nous sommes il est interpellé violemment
et il pouvait mourir vous pouvez mourir
la France est ce pays qui a cette les
Juifs de France et les Français juifs le
savent parfaitement y compris quand ils
sont en responsive
parce que Alfred Dreyfus est officier
d'état-major sorti de Polytechnique etc
ce qui est presque inimaginable dans la
plupart des autres pays chrétiens
environnants il y aurait jamais eu
d'affaires Dreyfus dans beaucoup de pays
parce qu'il y aurait jamais eu un juif
arrivant à ce niveau là mais évidemment
je voudrais vous prendre je précise
quand même que les dreyfusards on gagne
oui heureusement
c'est possible c'est assez exceptionnel
dans l'histoire
la leçon de la faire Dreyfus et je
voudrais vous interrogé sur cette
exotisme on a parlé de ces Juifs
républicains modérés mais il y a une
tendance
révolutionnaire pourquoi ces Juifs ont
investi ce terrain révolutionnaire vous
auriez la question à n'importe qui je
pense que vous auriez toujours la même
réponse à savoir que le sentiment de la
justice bon en remontant la généalogie
conduit à des comportements de radicaux
de radicaux Juifs bon et très
sincèrement ça peut se vérifier quand on
regarde ce que les antisémites n'ont pas
manqué de fer évidemment la composition
du parti pas envie de bolchevik ben oui
quand même ça c'est pas être antisémite
que de le constater et et on pourrait
dire d'organisation révolutionnaire plus
récente aux alentours 68 donc il y a
quand même un lien d'ailleurs évidemment
ça se retrouve dans les pays dit du
tirement parce que le rôle des Juifs
dans l'émancipation de pays qui se sont
révélés ensuite des pays nationalistes
arabes la sur-représentation de Juifs au
moment décisif
c'est le prophétisme juif vous savez
dans la tradition même par exemple
Jaurès qu'il n'avait rien de juif il
était catholique dit dans un discours
qu'il prononce ici à l'Assemblée
nationale en 1913 je crois le grand
discours pour la laïque non peut-être
1911 il dit heureusement les Juifs se
sont mêlés à la tradition
occidentale c'est le prophétisme juif et
c'est un immense mouvement de justice
pour un socialiste quand on dit immense
mouvement de justice c'est pas rien
puisque lui c'était quasiment sa
théologie laïque ça vient du prophétisme
juif donc les Juifs nous ont laissé ça
comme Merleau-Ponty disait la même chose
donc 30 ans plus tard lui aussi
catholique dit dans le fond c'est
d'ailleurs un moment de l'histoire du
judaïsme qui serait intéressant où on
garde plus le prophétisme que la loi
mosaïque mais ce prophétisme juif il
enseigne au monde cette impératif et
cette immense mouvement de justice donc
il est pas tout à fait impensable qu'on
le retrouve dans les mouvements
révolutionnaires
il y a une chose par rapport à votre
question de toute la première qui
rejoint cette idée parce que on ne s'est
pas fait clairement comprendre le peuple
juif c'est un peuple moyen c'est à dire
c'est un moyen entre quoi c'est le
premier à dire humanité universelle au
début mais je vous rappelle l'Espérance
à la fin les scatologie on se retrouvera
tous humanitaire à la fin et je suis
particulier parce que je maintiens cette
espérance de mon côté qu'on se retrouve
tous à la fin comme au début donc cette
idée que l'humanité et ça c'est très
moderne parce qu'on va le retrouver chez
Kanté que l'humanité est une au départ
et qu'elle doit se retrouver une à la
fin c'est ce que les Juifs ont apporté à
l'Occident c'est quelque chose de
considérable et on le retrouve dans les
mouvements révolutionnaires mais tout
mouvement cosmopolitique ou parliez tout
à l'heure de l'âge qu'elle a les signes
ce que ce que les signes dit l'époque de
madelson donc des Juifs c'est cette idée
de l'éducation du genre humain
c'est-à-dire cette idée qu'on va
retrouver après dans les cosmopolitiques
qu'il y a une humanité une parce qu'il y
a un dieu un parce qu'il y a une loi une
parce qu'il y a la même morale pour tous
et on doit la retrouver et quand les
Juifs se replient c'est parce que toutes
ces nations en guerre oublient ce
message et que ils ne sont particuliers
que pour tenir ce message universel mais
si tout le monde le prend c'est
d'ailleurs un peu l'espérance
protestante d'une certaine façon à la
fin il y aura plus de Juifs il y aura
une humanité une donc ce beau rêve là
qu'on retrouve dans les eschatologies
révolutionnaires alors dans les
théologies de la Libération nous
trotskies dans tout ce que vous voulez
vous les retrouvez dans le socialisme
français quand j'aurai dit ici à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est
l'enseignement de ces grands juifs et
qui dira dans Isa
une larme une larme qui coule encore sur
la joue de celui qui est pauvre qui est
opprimé il faut l'essuyer voilà il faut
voilà ce que nous devons faire donc ce
message-là
ça c'est la grande querelle pierre c'est
la grande querelle parce que c'est du
Christ la compassion la misagne c'est
pas c'est le pentate
quand même beaucoup beaucoup dans la
Bible juive mais je voudrais du tout
mais je voudrais parler de
devoir par jour le moment le plus
intense le cœur de la prière juive c'est
précédé par béni soit tu qui a choisi le
peuple d'Israël
par amour et juste après schéma Israël
qui est le truc central pardon je
voulais vous dire quelque chose
le
le problème c'est que la région juive
comme toutes les traditions contient
plusieurs courants et que quand on lit
Amos ou Ezekiel on a assez envie d'aller
sur les barricades mais
on a beaucoup moins envie d'aller sur
les barricades quand on étudie le Talmud
et que il y a un courant effectivement
prophétique il peut conduire au
socialisme révolutionnaire et il y a un
courant au contraire
où on vous explique que rien n'est
simple que il faut regarder tous les
détails que une vérité souvent compensée
par une autre vérité et c'est à dire un
petit problème de la partie philosémique
du christianisme dans le protestantisme
c'est que eux ils disent beaucoup les
prophètes ils disent pas du tout le
temps ils savent pas que ça existe et du
coup il rate je pense une grosse moitié
de l'identité juive qui est une moitié
qui n'est pas la moitié de partie
critique la partie le monde a changé
mais qui est la partie est le coûtons
paisiblement posément regardons la
situation et voyons quelles conséquences
en tirer et c'est vrai que les deux
coexistent parce que bah aucune culture
n'est entièrement cohérente et que c'est
comme ça non je veux dire un mot là
aussi un peu inopportun si je veux dire
c'est à dire que à notre génération il
s'est passé plusieurs phénomènes qui
nous ont fait
avoir un regard neuf et différents sur
le judaïsme il s'est passé au niveau de
toute notre génération une renaissance
de l'intérêt pour la pensée juive
oblitérée
par la philosophie chrétienne et qui de
maïmony dame delsson
a Roger à travers des gens comme Trigano
comme d'autres philosophes et c'est
toute une voilà qui est liée évidemment
à
la prise de conscience de l'unicité du
de du problème juif et à la tradition
positive judaïsme qui avait été très
largement au littéraire par la courant
simulateur
bon d'autres parts il y a eu
à la fois double phénomène qui ne peut
pas ne pas
bouleversant dans les deux cas
l'extermination masse on va industriel
c'est de justement de ça qu'on a
l'intention de parler dans la création
d'un État neutre
si profondément le regard qu'on peut
avoir que les Juifs d'Europe et on va et
sur la tradition juive
sur la singularité juive sur le destin
juif que on ne peut plus ne pas penser
la tradition juive à travers ces deux
phénomènes
alors selon un arête la mise hors la loi
du peuple juif en Europe a été suivi de
près par celle de la plupart des nations
européennes alors
vous l'avez évoqué Pierre Nora de
phénomène important au 20e siècle d'un
côté la Shoah de l'autre côté la
création d'Israël par rapport à notre
sujet qu'est-ce qui a changé
dans ce destin juif
je vais être un peu provocateur mais je
pense que le passage de l'anti judaïsme
a l'antisémitisme quand je dis pas ça
pour moi les deux continuent à ce
superposer à l'heure actuelle nous
parlons il y a tout un anti judaïsme de
source chrétienne ressources de source
musulmane qui prolifère donc c'est pas
c'est pas une substitution mais
l'antisémitisme j'allais dire il vient
entre guillemets de la gauche en tous
les cas il vient d'une pensée qui permet
de haïr les Juifs sans croire qu'il y a
un Dieu ce qui est quand même une
révolution et ça c'est l'antisémitisme
ce qui explique d'ailleurs certaines
formes d'antisémitisme récentes mais
plus fondamentalement ce qui n'en reste
dans l'itlerisme je suis désolé de le
dire à ce passe mais je voudrais pas
faire du freudisme de base étage mais il
est clair qu'après le trauma il faut
quand même utiliser des termes comme ça
même si les historiens doivent prendre
des pincettes avec ces métaphores
psychologiques mais quand même après le
trauma de la Shoah il me semble qu'il y
a eu quand même une volonté chez les non
juifs maintient toujours les non juifs
qui sont quand même majorité
quel que soit bon mais même qui était
majoritaire avant 33 aussi une volonté
d'aller explorer cette culture juive au
glitterrée etc moi j'ai parlé dans mon
petit livre que je faisais une émission
tout à l'heure de 30 glorieuses de la
vidéo Philippe parce que à force de
travailler sur les phobies x on oublie
qu'il y a des xénon Philippe
heureusement bon et franchement prenez
la chronologie des expositions des
rééditions des débats des colloques
entre pour s'appliquer 1950 et 1900
justement 60 ça commence à se compliquer
vers 75 comme par hasard bien là vous
avez un moment où la culture juive lui
revienne etc
j'y vois quelque part un effet d'un
sentiment de culpabilité mais non juifs
il faut quand même le dire bon
c'est-à-dire
de culpabilité du lapin des dons juifs
et de la part des Juifs le sentiment que
quelque chose leur était réservé en
propre
qui est l'extermination et que ça suffit
à faire deux une réappropriation comme
on disait dans ces années 70 de leur
singularité vous avez un changement qui
se lit immédiatement les deux plus
grands intellectuels français en
philosophie avant guerre sont Léon
brunchvik et Henri Bergson ce sont les
deux maîtres absolus de l'université
tous les deux sont juifs personne ne le
dit jamais à cette époque ça n'a pas
d'intérêt et une le revendique pas
personne a d'ailleurs failli à la fin de
sa vie vous le savez sans doute se
convertir après la guerre changement
total nous juifs français nous avons
voulu jouer totalement le jeu de la
République les fous de la République de
Bird baume c'est grand professeurs de
Sorbonne mais vous appelez
Laurent Pierre-François Zulte la police
de Vichy venait quand même frapper à
votre porte et vous déporter donc
l'interrogation de ceux qui sont après
45 néer les vinasses c'est cette
assimilation cette édulcoration nos
différences elle nous a conduit à quoi
personne nous en a été reconnaissant
parce que même quand nous nous vivions
pas comme juifs il y a des Juifs
français qui ont été déportés et tués
qui ne se vivaient pas comme des Juifs
il y a un bel exemple c'est Marc bloc ah
bien sûr bah bien sûr absolument le
Grand qui grandissent rien mort dans les
conditions que vous savez résistant etc
etc et qui quand même dans la société
féodale en particulier ne parle
pratiquement pas des Juifs
donc vous avez un voyage
très important
mais ça n'a pas aidé
il faut le comprendre les textes de
l'évinage sur la simulation sont
extraordinaires parce qu'il dit dans le
fond de se rendait pas compte qu'on
respirait une atmosphère chrétienne et
que dans cette atmosphère chrétienne
puisqu'on disait on est tous à égalité
dans la République il y a toujours
quelque chose malgré tout de la
judéophobie qui vient de très loin bon
et c'est tous les travaux qui ont lieu
avec l'historien Jul Isaac après et les
amitiés évidemment le dialogue contre
les juifs et les chrétiens et puis
Israël Israël en 48 alors là c'est votre
livre de danitrome dans la tradition
historique des Juifs ça leur a été
beaucoup reproché et on disait les Juifs
vont être protégés par les princes le
fait qu'il devenait donc c'est c'est les
livres de hier ou chalmy qui montent
très bien ça l'historien est rouge admis
et donc serviteur de roi parce que nous
allions avoir la protection des
populations par des rapports directement
au puissants cette époque est révolue ça
n'a pas marché et ça a été quand même la
surprise la surprise de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et de la Shoah c'est on
ne pensait pas les Juifs que pensez pas
que ça pouvait arriver bon donc derrière
il faut qu'il pensait pas que la Shoah
pouvait arriver qu'il y aurait
d'extermination de masse uniquement bien
entendu d'ailleurs ça a été reproché par
des plus jeunes qu'ils aient vous n'avez
pas vu la difficulté venir vous êtes
laissé endormir parlait etc vous n'avez
pas quitté l'appartement moi je vois
dans ma famille certains heureusement
sont allés les chercher mais en tu peux
rien nous arriver vous savez
heureux comme un juif en France en 1930
il venait de toute l'Europe en France
pour trouver un avis voilà
Israël vient jouer et ça change
totalement notre pensée complètement le
choix et nous ne sommes plus les mêmes
dans la République parce que cette
crainte est là on ne peut pas avoir été
les enfants de gens qui ont vécu ça et
Pierre est une génération qu'il a connu
et ne pas l'avoir là quelque part ça
et deuxièmement Israël quel est le rôle
d'Israël par rapport à la diaspora et
évidemment c'est le livre de Trump Drôme
dit c'est maintenant Israël qui est pour
nous est quand même le grand protecteur
l'antisémitisme existe la violence à
l'égard des Juifs existent toujours pas
qu'à le regard d'ailleurs mais à leur
égard mais il y a quelque part Israël
Israël
pourquoi c'est compliqué pour des
raisons pour des raisons politiques mais
ces raisons politiques vont tellement
loin on a longtemps cru que dans le
rapport israélien diaspora Israël avait
une sorte de leadership pour dire oui
que c'était là que je réalisais
l'essence du judaïsme qu'à la limite
c'était là qu'il fallait aller pour être
vrai juif etc et que la diaspora était
en quelque sorte on marge une sorte de
juiverie et filocher et pas tout à fait
cacher le
est-ce que ça ne s'est pas renversé
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui d'une certaine
façon je le dis avec
prudence c'est pas Israël qui est le
boulet et pas la diaspora est-ce que
c'est pas en diaspora qui se passe des
choses intéressantes pas du jour en
Israël sont dans le domaine scientifique
littéraire etc mais pas dans le domaine
proprement
civique politique etc et ce est
l'évolution politique d'Israël qui est
probablement pas circonstanciel mais qui
vient de loin
ça vous laisse sceptique Armand
lafférrer sur ce point sur ce point les
règles je pense à peu près exactement
l'inverse donc c'est bien ça crée de la
je reviens pas tellement sur la Shoah la
Shoah ne définit pas le judaïs la chose
c'est ce qui a voulu détruire le gtaïsme
et ils ont échoué donc ça ne le définit
que dans la mesure où ils ont ils sont
pas parvenus nous sommes encore là
Israël pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important parce que c'est
au fond c'est le retour à la normale un
peuple à son pays c'est ça qui est comme
ça que ça devrait être il ne peut pas
être lugueux
on va être d'accord on sait le retour à
la normale un peuple à son pays ça y est
les Juifs ont leur pays de nouveau ça
fait 1927 c'était pas le cas mais c'est
le cas mais ça a des conséquences ça a
des conséquences très importantes c'est
que une bonne partie de la tradition qui
s'était créée parce qu'il n'y avait pas
de pays sans perdre son intérêt sans
perdre sa valeur doit forcément être un
peu remise en cause tout ce qui est
l'ajout de la loi juive tout ce qui est
Lara a été défin
et le judaïsme en partie lié vous êtes
allés sur les textes du 19e siècle pour
puiser ce républicanisme juif je
voudrais signaler quand même un ouvrage
important d'un auteur qui prend de plus
en plus d'importance je parle de Walter
ben Yamine et c'est une très belle
biographie par le grand historien
israélien le kabbalisme garchon Chelem
je voudrais signaler votre ouvrage
armant la Ferrer lecture politique de la
Bible donc pour vous il y a donc une
lecture politique de la Bible en deux
mots parce qu'on a plus de temps 250
pages mais en gros le livre c'est pour
comment les Juifs ont inventé la
séparation des pouvoirs et ont inventé
la nécessité de restreindre le pouvoir
voilà
je voudrais signaler de vous ce côté
obscur du peuple chez bouquin c'est quoi
ce côté obscur du peuple c'est la
situation dans laquelle aujourd'hui
c'est à dire tout ce qu'on met sous les
vocable de populisme de ce que
j'ajouterai la démocratie autoritaire
qui n'est pas un oxymore ce que dans la
définition de la démocratie il y a pas
un espace pour la liberté je voudrais le
signaler au passage c'est la démocratie
libérale qui est libérale mais la
démocratie n'a aucune raison
particulière d'être libérale mais ça
c'est bon voilà un grand débat alors
Pierre Nora on a déjà parlé une étrange
obstination là c'est un peu
la biographie d'un intellectuel dans le
siècle c'est votre cas puisque vous avez
traversé vous avez traversé ce siècle et
c'est un témoignage en fait vous en
faites un lieu de mémoire en quelque
sorte vous diriez ça vous diriez ça vous
diriez ça d'époque qui cherche à
faire revivre une comme on dit une
époque sans pareil comme on dit une
année sans pareil ces années 50-90 qui
ont connu une effervescence intelle
historienne en France unique voilà alors
je voudrais signaler également un numéro
spécial de la revue passage qui est
consacrée aux grandes figures juives
d'Alsace Lorraine et c'était une
extraordinaire concentration de
Lévi-Strauss à Durkheim de rémoison à
René Cassin on s'interroge pourquoi
cette concentration dans cette région
transfrontalière il me reste à vous
remercier messieurs d'avoir participé à
cette émission que pour ma part j'ai
trouvé fort intéressante et fort
instructive je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de SCP et avant de nous quitter
je voudrais vous laisser avec cette
pensée de Thomas man l'histoire se
compose des événements accomplis et de
ceux qui ne cessent de se dérouler dans
le temps